well there is no show today that's the
bad news uh
the bosses were upset that i've been
complaining about the hotel
accommodation so much and so they've
fired me they said uh if i don't like
the hotel i can go back to being
homeless in my car
uh no that's not actually what happened
at all we just are traveling and that's
why we can't unfortunately do a show
today but the good news is that we still
have some content to feed to you my
sweet babies i would never let you
starve from a lack of content so we got
something special a little bit of
relationship advice that i'll be doling
out on a friday that's coming up in just
a second but i want to tell you that
this video is brought to you by 40 days
for life and there's no better time to
talk about 40 days for life after the
texas abortion ban and all the
discussion uh about abortion that has
been reignited in the last week you know
what we find for a lot of conservatives
who
who who have the right view on this
topic uh still
aren't always prepared to discuss and
defend their pro-life views and that's
why 40 days life has just released the
perfect book for those looking to arm
themselves against a broad range of
pro-choice talking points titled what to
say when the complete new guide to
discussing abortion the book is an easy
read for individuals looking to defend
life and convert hearts a lot has
changed of course since abortion was
legalized in 1973 what to say when
equips readers with proven approaches to
dismantling the pro-abortion agenda
these methods have already enabled 40
days for life members to convert the
hearts of 221
abortion workers and another nice thing
about this book is that i actually wrote
the foreword for it so i can endorse it
personally and i also even though i talk
about these issues all the time i really
enjoyed reading the book and i learned a
lot from it as well so what to say when
the complete new guide to discussing
abortion uh you can get that with free
shipping and 21 off a signed hardback at
40daysforlife.com
what to say
when and that's what's sponsoring the
video you're about to watch also
speaking of videos on monday though
we're also not going to be doing a show
nobody in the company will be but we
have something very special on monday if
you if you check back on youtube we're
going to finally have our sweet baby
gang anthem contest you don't want to
miss that we're going to finally select
uh what our what the anthem is that
we'll that will reverberate through our
hearts for for all time so make sure you
check for that on monday i'll be back on
tuesday godspeed my sweet babies check
out the video
you know one thing i do sometimes on
this channel is dispense relationship
advice it's been a little while since
our last relationship advice segment i
think and i know that couples across
america and the world really are hanging
in the balance falling apart
unsure what to do without my guidance
and so i'm back to to be that guiding
light for you again as we return to the
relationship advice forum on reddit to
settle these disputes answer questions
repair broken bonds
let's check it out we'll start with uh
this question here says
my girlfriend of two years just revealed
to me that she might want to try a
one-off every so often in our otherwise
monogamous relationship in which we
would message the other person that
we're taking a night off meaning taking
someone else home and having sex with
them that night
we're gonna have sex with other people
but otherwise we're gonna be monogamous
i don't think it means what you think it
means you know i'm a vegetarian other
than three or four times a day that i
meet it's kind of a similar thing
for context we're talking about sexual
preferences and it sort of struck me out
of nowhere because she so far led me to
believe she's a pretty possessive and
sometimes jealous girlfriend who doesn't
like to share her significant other it
came as a little bit of a shock because
i definitely wouldn't be okay with it
and she knows that i prefer monogamy in
long-term relationships we tried talking
out a little in which i stayed in my
case but i'm just kind of worried that
she might want that in the distant
future
if we get engaged and eventually married
like we've talked about in the past any
advice is welcome well you're not gonna
get uh engaged or married because what
you're gonna do is break up bye felicia
this uh she's asking for permission to
cheat she's probably already cheating
this is probably more of a
this is more of her seeking validation
after the fact
for what she's already done but even if
it isn't she's telling you i don't i'm
not interested in being committed to you
which means what's the
in what sense are you even in a
relationship at all that's an easy one
just be done with her and break up uh
glad we could settle that all right next
it says i feel like i'm not allowed to
have my own time i've been dating my
girlfriend for almost half a year now
and it's been mostly great other than
her clinginess
she's the type to send multiple walls of
text while i'm at work and then when i
give her a quick response trying to
explain to her i'm busy she thinks i'm
upset at her which in reality i i am and
i've tried to explain to her that
there's no need to blow my phone up when
i'm on the clock at work or at school
i'm trying to explain to her i'm busy
and i've even set boundaries for her to
not borderline spam me when i don't
reply but i feel like when i bring this
up she thinks you don't want me to text
you at all she's also tried calling me
while i'm at work and when i don't
answer she'll text my parents asking if
i'm safe
there's also been instances of me having
to text her to get her to let me be when
i'm hanging out with a friend uh okay i
think we'll get the idea here
extremely clingy extremely needy once
again i would say break up bafflation uh
now granted
you guys have been dating for half a
year you'd say which uh which means
you've barely been together at all okay
so you're you're still babies in a
relationship
and she's still in the infatuation stage
of things and every couple has the
infatuation stage when you're sort of
obsessed with each other and you need to
be around each other 24 7. which there's
no love before the infatuation
is gets in the way of love there can't
be real love because
the infatuation state stage is
self-focused you're obsessed with how
this person makes you feel
so it's all about you she's texting and
calling you all the time not because
she's actually worried about you but
more that she needs that constant
connection with you for her own self she
doesn't really care if she's intruding
on you or not so it's really not about
you at all it's more about her
tell me i'm pretty tell me i'm pretty
there's probably nothing beneath the
infatuation except the infatuation
itself this will be one of those
situations where you stay with her and
then in a few months she gets bored and
just breaks up with you all so she'll go
from
utterly obsessed with you she too she
doesn't want any anything to do with you
just like that or she'll cheat or
something so i just cut this one off now
i mean general rule here
if you've been dating for only six
months
and she's already annoying the hell out
of you every second of the day
not a good sign so i would uh
just leave that one alone
you know just to cut in here very
quickly you know what this all reminds
me of
magnesium especially magnesium
breakthrough by by optimizer listen if
you're having trouble falling asleep or
staying asleep one of the best things
you could possibly do is start getting
enough magnesium if i've said it once
i've said it a thousand times but please
do not run to the store to buy the first
magnesium supplement you find most
magnesium supplements use only the two
cheapest synthetic forms and since
they're not full spectrum
they won't fix your magnesium deficiency
or help you sleep better that's no good
that's why you need buy optimizer there
are actually seven unique forms of uh
magnesium and you must get all of them
if you want to experience its calming
sleep enhancing effects that's why i
recommend magnesium breakthrough by bi
optimizers simply take two capsules
before you go to bed and you'll be
amazed by how much better you sleep and
how much more rest did you feel when you
wake up so for an exclusive offer for my
listeners go to www.magbreakthrough.com
walsh and use codewalsh10 to save 10 off
when you try magnesium by optimizer oh
and one more thing for a limited time
buy optimizers is also giving away free
bottles of their best-selling products
uh p30m
and mass zymes with select purchases so
go to www.magbreakthrough.com
welsh now to get your exclusive 10
discount plus the chance to get more
than 50 worth of 50 worth of supplements
for free
and also once a month you know the hosts
of daily wire come together
on backstage for some light-hearted
debate and some sometimes not so
lighthearted debate as well but it's
always a very interesting a lot of fun
i'm extremely excited to tell you that
our backstage in october is going to be
staged a little bit differently instead
of just tuning in from your home you'll
be able to see us live and on stage at
the famous ryman auditorium right here
in nashville doing what we do best which
is making sense so join myself candace
owens jeremy boring ben shapiro michael
knowles andrew clavin for a backstage
like never before pre-sale tickets sold
out within hours yesterday and general
admission tickets went on sale at 10 a.m
today we're offering three different
kinds of tickets vip tickets that come
with an exclusive gift and a meet and
greet with the daily wire talent
followed by a ticket that comes with
upgraded seating and a show poster and
finally tickets for general seating for
all you cheapskates whichever ticket you
choose i guarantee it's going to be a
good time hurry though because uh if
this is these tickets aren't going to
last forever so head to dailywire.com
ryman to purchase your tickets before
they sell out
my husband and i have been together for
13 years married for five at the
beginning of our relationship he was
super affectionate holding hands
cuddling with me the whole nine yards
we've always gotten along great and had
a really positive fulfilling
relationship in every sense of the word
not surprisingly after being together
this long things have changed i've
noticed in the past year or so that he's
been much more physically distant he's
not affectionate at all anymore and our
sex life has dwindled to once a week and
seemingly unenthusiastically on his part
when i've asked him about this he always
tells me it's just because he's getting
older and isn't interested in sex
anymore about the not being affectionate
thing he says grown men don't like being
hugged and stuff
yeah
the final straw was me getting covered
and having to sleep in separate rooms to
quarantine he said he still wants to
sleep in separate rooms telling me it's
because he sleeps better we still get
along and have a lot of fun together but
i feel like at this point he treats me
like a roommate instead of a wife i
don't want to leave him but i also don't
think
3038 is too old to give up on a romantic
relationship entirely
uh okay so
i'm gonna take the opposite approach
here and say that breaking up divorcing
shouldn't even be on the table what
worries me the most in this whole thing
is that you said uh i don't want to
leave him but right like that shouldn't
be in the discussion at all of course
you're not going to leave him for this
that doesn't make him right in what he's
doing and how he's treating you but this
is not a divorce situation not even
close to it this is what's known as a
rough patch
happens in marriages sometimes the only
thing that makes a little bit unusual is
the bit where he doesn't want to sleep
in the same room and that you can't
allow it all that's a death knell
separate rooms i mean then you really
are roommates not to mention if you have
kids the message that sends to them so
that's no good as for the rest of this
you know you have to let him know what
your emotional needs are and that it's
not all about him
but
that should be something you could talk
about one other thought here
married for five years together for 13.
so you were together for seven or eight
years before marriage
this is maybe yet another reason why
long engagements or courtships or dating
periods or whatever are not very good
because you're hitting this rough period
these kind of doldrums
way earlier than you should be because
you were already eight years in
by the time you even walked down the
aisle
and that means you hit your rough patch
as
you you know you hit your rough patch
early
and you aren't going to have all these
many many years of marriage behind you
as to serve as a stable foundation to
see you through and that's part of the
problem you want to be sick of each
other
like once you've been married for a
while
i'm kidding of course i mean
the doldrums and the rough patches it's
not inevitable not every marriage has
them but it can happen
and i'm suggesting that you're on a bit
of a sped up timeline because of your
very very long pre-season so cut the
preseason down get right to the main to
the season can't do anything about that
now so i would say just talk it out okay
that's great advice for me
just talk about it what do you want me
to do
that would make a terrible therapist
maybe we should chug on over to mamby
pamby land where maybe we can find some
self-confidence for you you jack wagon
okay one more here this says um
i feel that my girlfriend can be the
perfect future wife but i'm afraid that
i met her too early in life
i've been with her for four years since
i was 15 she was my first real
relationship she's the one i lost my
virginity to we've had our ups and downs
but everything right now is going great
she's really mature for her age and
that's why i think she'd be a good wife
my problem is that i don't know if i
want to spend my whole life having only
been with one woman she's the only one
i've ever had sex with and i fear that
my romantic and sex life will become
boring due to the lack of diversity i
don't even know if sex is that great
since i don't have any other references
adding to that there's a few girls that
are interested in me and sometimes when
i think about it i find myself wanting
to be with them so basically i want to
live my youth and have a few experiences
with different women but i don't know if
i can leave my girlfriend because i
don't know if i'll be able to find a
wife as good as her in the future okay
so she could be the perfect wife but you
want to find someone who is what more
perfect
you want references what is this a job
search you want you want to be able to
compare her to other women for
why for what reason
no you got to grow up son this this
isn't even a grass is greener on the
other side situation
because you don't think the grass is
greener as you admit you just think that
it might be different it's different
grass
and you want to you want different grass
for difference for the sake of
difference grass
different for differences sake or
diversity as you put it
this is you know what this is like i'll
tell you what this is like
this is like when you're walking through
an airport and there's a pot belly
sandwich shop right there but you say no
no no no
i'm not going to get the sandwich there
even though i know it's delicious i'm
going to keep walking see if i find
something better maybe there'll be
something better at my gate and then you
get to your gate and all there is is
like a kiosk with a refrigerator and
some soggy sandwiches and saran wrap and
maybe a cup of like macaroni salad or
something and um
but it's too late to go back to the pot
belly
come to think of this analogy is not
very good so let's just
just take that as advice on how to
handle airports and where to find food
as for relationships
when you find the person who you know
would make a good and devoted and loving
spouse
you've won you've completed the game
congratulations that's that's
that's the objective you've com that's
you're there
no need to keep looking
continuing to date and sleep around and
whatever none of that is going to help
you
in the long run and you'll be you'll
what you're practicing then is just
basically disloyalty heartbreak breakups
that's the experience you'll be getting
and that's the experience you're gonna
bring into your marriage
when eventually you do go down that road
a road that you could have walked years
before don't make that mistake young man
and uh take
what is right in front of you and that
is my fatherly lecture for the day i
don't know if any of this advice will be
useful to any of you except for the
airport bit that is really important
when you see the pot bellies go for it
um but there it was
if you uh want more relationship advice
where i basically just tell all of you
to break up and live lonely and
miserable lives in your solitude then
make sure to like and subscribe right
now